Oh Senor Presidente
which one dear only occurs cloggers
whether that in issue analysis sound
degree six Masters was regards state
Alberta sound a premier pond to the
warden to DA a
Clarisonic myself who started the
delayed a Malta the pastor central
science Sabrosa Cena to the daphne
karana galicia claim wattage pepsi vasu
sattar curtains / of pasta mentors catch
the eye occur Tamas Oh carrot reverse to
assist traditional carrot reversal stem
electronic you come where pratik
abattoir now consider I confer a curtain
Azul primera hundred intervention group
politics must are aware to put him into
the car domicile parish interval science
skin he say my mother from the towns are
in issue Norbert ich most bizarre
palabra commissar a commissary a very
sure over he came so we'll do the Agora
dispels who very much mr. president
honorable members I would first like to
thank you for putting the situation of
the rule of law in Malta on today's
agenda it is essential that all EU
institutions contribute within their
respective roles to upholding the rule
of law in the EU in this regard
the recent visit
the European Parliament's delegation in
Malta and today's debate are of great
importance as president von der Leyen
made clear she is concerned by recent
developments in Malta the Commission has
been following the developments in Malta
very closely the Commission condemns the
assassination of journalist Daphne
Carwin Eritrea her murder was an attack
on the free media and is a grave concern
of to Europe as a whole media freedom is
the foundation of our free and
democratic society journalists must feel
safe to work in Europe if not democracy
as we know it will be under threat it is
not the Commission's Roe to comment on
ongoing national investigations but we
have said it very clearly many times
that we expect a thorough and
independent investigation free from any
political interference I repeated this
message directly to the Maltese
ministers I spoke to recently Europe
Paul is in Malta and has supported the
investigations in Malta as a top
priority case with experts on the spot
and from Europol at waters the support
activities are ongoing and will continue
it is crucial that all those responsible
are brought to justice as soon as
possible the people of Malta and first
and foremost the family of Daphne coruña
Galicia demand truth and justice and we
stand with them I also made this very
clear during my visit to Malta in June
2018 our role the role of the Commission
is to address more structural and
systemic issues in particular in the
area of judiciary and the fight against
corruption and money laundering and we
have done just that the Commission has
already been clear on the issue
there are a number of structural reforms
that Malta is undertaking or needs to
undertake this was clearly stated in the
European semester country specific
recommendations which were adopted by
the Council on the 9th of july 2019 the
commission also brought infringement
procedures regarding the incomplete
transposition of the anti-money
laundering directive and adopted an
opinion on measures to be taken by the
anti-money laundering supervisor
following the adoption of a finding of
breach of union law by the European
Banking Authority and we are not the
only ones on whose advice Malta can rely
in its opinion of December 2018 the
Venice Commission and it in its
evaluation report on Malta in April 2000
19:00 the group of states against
corruption of the Council of Europe also
raised a number of concerns in line with
those of the Commission the Commission
is in regular contact with the Maltese
authorities and will continue working
with the authorities to accelerate these
reforms I will in particular highlight
the following priorities for urgent
action one of the top priorities for
Malta is to strengthen the independence
of the judiciary in particular the
safeguards for judicial appointments and
dismissals and to establish a separate
and fully independent prosecution
service there is also a need to
strengthen efforts to detect and
prosecute corruption and the enforcement
of the anti-money laundering framework I
am aware that the Maltese authorities
have at several occasions expressed
their intention to proceed with the
necessary reforms in the areas of
concern I have mentioned but there is
still a lack of significant progress the
latest developments show that no further
time should be lost
the Commission has underlined that any
reform must comply with EU law and
European standards relating to the wharf
law
have strongly encouraged Malta to
properly consult the Venice Commission
as regards the prosecution services
motor adopted the state advocate act in
july 2019 and appointed its first state
advocate however concerns remain as
regards among others the lack of checks
and balances in the appointment
procedure of the Attorney General which
in practice is still under the power of
the prime minister the Commission
expects the Maltese authorities to
implement info the recommendations of
the Venice Commission and to follow up
on the findings and recommendations of
the European Commission we are in
contact with the authorities
Commissioner winders and I both talked
with justice minister bonnet last week
and we will continue to insist on the
need to accelerate the reforms just
yesterday Commissioner Rangers and
elected to the Maltese authorities
outlining the concerns and need for
speedier reforming let me emphasize that
the rule of law issues our European
issues the EU is built on mutual trust
among its members and each European
citizen deserves justice this is why we
will continue to closely follow the
situation we stand ready to work with
the Maltese authorities on all these
aspects and to provide support where
necessary more generally we will soon
put in place a new rule of law mechanism
covering all Member States including
motor to improve prevention dialogue and
monitoring this will cover judicial
independence as well as anti-corruption
and aspects of media pluralism relevant
to the rule of law honourable members I
can assure you that the Commission will
not hesitate to take measures as
necessary thank you
[Applause]